stockholm sweden june 12 1972
mrs indira gandhi prime minister of
india arrived today to address the first
united nations conference on the human
environment it is clear
that the environmental crisis which is
confronting the world will profoundly
alter the future destiny of our planet
you would think that that global
awareness of the planet's predicament
half a century ago would have corrected
our trajectory towards a climate
catastrophe but instead more coal more
oil more gas was burned and we are where
we are today in a world where
biodiversity is in collapse where deadly
heat waves and wildfires tell a grim
truth where environmental disaster seems
to be a weekly event somewhere in the
world the importance of this moment is
well 50 years ago those reports set out
very very clearly what was needed to be
done and it hasn't been done and of
course we now find ourselves pretty much
on the edge of catastrophe whether we're
talking about waste pollution climate
growing inequality poverty
the stockholm declaration did presage
the age of the environmental conference
with successes like the paris agreement
in 2015
but these events are at the intersection
at which science and political
self-interest collide and progress can
be elusive to say the least
but progress is needed now on some
perilously important issues like how the
planet feeds and powers itself
we couldn't be in a more
important place in in in the history of
society i would i would say and so i
think it is critical that that people
turn their eyes towards stockholm and
and really see it as a key moment
in 1972 we saw the early days of
environmental activism
they awarded a series of prizes to the
olympic champions of pollution
may we have the first award for
automobile pollution
the protest movement has moved on since
but the message is the same spearheaded
today by another product of stockholm
this has been a time where we have been
reminded of how vulnerable we are
our current predicament reinforces a
point made 50 years ago which today is
more valid and troubling than ever
no one amongst us whatever our status
strength or circumstance can remain
unaffected
there have been certain victories like
mending the hole in the ozone layer or
eradicating the production of leaded
fuel but those gathered in stockholm 50
years on now confront perhaps the
ultimate challenge to bring us back from
the brink of a climate emergency
nick clark al jazeera